Speaker 1: But you know who's not getting
rewarded right now?
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham last week
in the state of South Carolina, the Aiken
County Republican Party.
Voted to censure Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham now so far this year, when we have
seen Republicans come out and censure their
own members, usually it's because they've
either said they don't agree with Donald Trump's
big lie or they've, you know.
Pretty much it's only been if they aren't
blindly loyal to Trump, so did Lindsey Graham
do something we don't know about?
No, it's actually much worse than that.
What Lindsey Graham's crime is, according
to this Aiken County Republican Party, in
their censure.
He voted to allow the infrastructure bill
to move forward.
And they censured him for it.
Just because he voted to allow the thing to
move forward and then, of course, he praised
the bipartisan infrastructure bill, the trillion
dollar bill praised it, that's a good thing.
But in today's Republican Party.
It's not only that you have to be blindly
loyal to Trump, but now it's you can't even
vote.
On a bipartisan piece of legislation without
facing backlash from your party.
Because if that's the case, we're doomed.
And this country is doomed.
Because that's what this is this is a bipartisan
infrastructure bill that should go much further
than it does.
But, you know, we got the three and a half
trillion bill coming up behind it.
Hopefully reconciliation will get that going.
But either way, this is a bill that is broadly
supported across America by Republicans and
Democrats and independents.
Everybody, a majority of them support this.
And they want this piece of legislation because
they know that infrastructure means jobs.
Infrastructure means work.
Infrastructure means investments in local
economies.
But apparently the folks over at the Aiken
County Republican Party didn't get that memo.
And they voted to censure him.
Is this a new era?
Have we finally entered the era here in the
United States where neither party can vote
with the other one on a piece of legislation
where everything has to be so damn kindergarden,
black and white with these people, where if
it's not a Republican bill, you have to vote
against it?
Even if Republicans worked on it, like with
the infrastructure bill?
Nope.
Republicans all always have to vote together
and Democrats always all have to vote together.
Tribalism is killing us here in the United
States, the two party system tribalism is
killing us here in the United States.
This infrastructure package is decades overdue,
folks.
And because Lindsey Graham actually said,
yeah, this is a good thing, he gets punished
for it by these Aiken County Republicans.
That's just nuts, and there's no other way
to say that this is ridiculous.
We cannot allow our country to get to the
point where there is no bipartisanship allowed,
where there's no negotiations allowed.
Because if we ever truly hit that point, which
apparently is where the Aiken County Republicans
want us to go, then we're done.
That's it.
Pack it up, start something new, because America
is not going to continue to function.
If we ever hit that point where these Aiken
County Republicans clearly want to take us.
I